This paper will deal with a problem
which is quite acute now as it was
3500 years ago-
of leadership.
And it will be limited
restricted to this sidra Beha’alotcha.
which is one of the most difficult sidras
in the entire Chumash in the entire Pentateuch.
The sidra of Beha'alotcha is very puzzling.
it is puzzling for two reasons.
First
certain events described in the sidra
are incomprehensible.
We simply do not know
why they happened, the etiology of those events,
and what purpose
were they pursuing.
I'll give you just an example. What I want to
explain. We do not understand the story about Miriam,
Miriam's criticism of Moses. Her disapproval.
It is hard to grasp
that Miriam,
the devoted and loyal sister who as a little girl
stood alone
on the shore of the Nile, to watch the floating ark,
because she had faith and hope,
as far as her brother is concerned,
her little brother
the baby in the ark, while all adults
including the mother and father, resigned and
abandoned the baby.
This sister
it is quite puzzling
should suddenly turn into an accuser?
Into prosecuting attorney?
Of her great brother.
Strange
Equally un-understandable
incomprehensible, is the strictness and the sadness
and the speed with which the Almighty meted out
the punishment.
Equally difficult to grasp,
is the connection between this episode and the tragedy
which
which was recorded in the Torah
prior to the description of the Miriam episode,
namely the tragedy of “Kivrot haTa’avah”
of the graves of the voluptuaries.
This is one difficulty.
There is a second difficulty.
Moses went through many crises.
he lived through many distressful experiences
and moments.
The worst of all, you understand
you know that- was the Egel (Golden Calf).
Experience which threatened to terminate the very
relationship between God and Israel.
Yet he was never panicked.
He never did act out of despair, black despair.
He never complained.
On the contrary, steadfastly and heroically,
he petition the Almighty for forgiveness.
Defending like an attorney
in the court, defending
the people, arguing their case.
Chazal express themselves by using a metaphor:
Vay’chal Moshe
Vay'chal in contradistinction to vay'ivakesh.
In contradistinction to
Vayitchanen Moshe,
emphasizes the element of strength and boldness.
There is both prayer and there is prayer,
humble prayer. Vay'chal has the connotation of both prayer
so Chazal say in a very strange metaphor
but it's a beautiful metaphor,
Moses seized the corner of the mantle (kaveyachol) of the Almighty
he said I will not let you loose
unless you forgive the sin of the people.
Suddenly,
Moshe began to complain in our sidra.
When the "asafsuf", the multitude began to rebel,
Moshe,
instead of defending the people, began to complain
almost accusing the people.
He even said things
which were never uttered.
“And Moshe said to Hashem: Why have you treated your servant so badly?
Why have I not found favor in your sight,
that you lay the burden of all this people on me?
I am not able to carry all this people alone, for they are too heavy for me.
If this is the way you are going to treat me,
put me to death at once if I have found favor in your sight and do not let me see my misery.”
Words which have never been uttered by Moses.
Yes, a similar phrase he uttered,
when he was sent to Pharaoh
on his first errand,
and his mission ended in complete failure.
So he came back to Hakadosh Baruch Hu, and he said
"Why have you mistreated this people? Why did you ever send me?"
However he never repeated his question.
It was a question of the young,
a man who is not experienced.
But Moshe as the leader
who took the Jews out of Egypt,
never repeated this question.
it is not Moshe like,
to act like a frightened
person and to speak out of the depths of resignation
as if he were... and to condemn the people.
However, this I gave you two examples
of events which require interpretation to understand.
We have to study Chumash the way we study Gemara.
You have to analyze, conceptualize the Chumash,
and find in every verse the meaning
the connotation,
and actually the tenet, the principle.
However, the most difficult problem with Beha'alotcha,
is not so much
is not limited to the substance of events
as depth of continuity of the sidra.
At first glance we are perplexed by the lack
of systematic development of the story
which the Torah was trying to tell us.
The latter (the Torah) is always
was always careful
about continuity and wholeness of the narrative.
The Torah never tells us half a story.
There's always development, transition,
complete narration.  When the Torah is finished with
the story, the story is complete.
However, as far as Beha'alotcha is concerned, we don't know.  We don't know
how many stories there are in Beha'alotcha.
How many stories are complete,
how many are incomplete.
And simply you don't see the continuity.
We don't see the thread of continuity in Beha'alotcha.
Let us just simply review Beha'alotcha.
The events which were recorded in the sidra of Beha'alotcha.
It starts, Beha'alotcha commences,
with what?  With the sanctification of the Levites.
Beha'alotcha took some psukim to the Menorah,
Chazal were right that
Beha'alotcha et haNerot (the Mitzvah of the Menorah)
actually belongs in parshat Naso.
That’s what Rashi wanted to convey when he said: Aharon became upset
So indeed, the sidre of Beha'alotcha
begins with the kiddush HaLeviim (sanctification of the Levites).
“and you shall present them as an elevation offering”
Then the Torah
tells us
about what?
What follows the kiddush HaLeviim?
Pesach Sheni
It is Pesach baShana haShenit (Pesach in the second year)
and Pesach Sheni.
Halakhically, Pesach Sheni
refers to the Pesach
which is offered in Iyar.
by the one who is far away and the one who is impure (at the time of the first Pesach).
But here the story is of the Pesach baShana haShenit
baShana haShenit.
And of course the Torah is recorded
within the framework of the Pesach baShana haShenit,
the incident with the tmei'im (impure ones).
They approached Moshe,
"why must we be kept from presenting Hashem’s offering
at its appointed time among the Israelites?"
And Moshe inquired of the Almighty,
and the institution of Pesach Sheni was established.
Where is the transition from the kiddush haleviim
to Pesach beShana haShenit?
We don't know.
Two different stories,
there is no continuous development.
Then following the description of
Peshach beShana haShenit and Pesach Sheni,
we have another description.
Of what?
Of the cloud. The Amud Ha'anan,
guiding the people on their journey.
There is no transition from the story about the Pesach,
to the story about Amud Ha'anan.
And the Torah tells us in detail
how the journeys of the Bnei Yisrael
are completely dependent
upon the position of Amud Ha'anan.
"Whenever the cloud lifted from over the tent, then the Israelites would set out…"
Following the narrative about the anan,
the Torah relates to us
the commandment pertaining to Chatzotzrot.
The two trumpets.
And their use for assembling the community
and the journeying of the camps.
And the Torah describes almost in detail
the signal system
connected with the Chatzotzrot.
One blast, one camp moved,
another blast, a second camp moved.
I mean the T’ruah, the T’ki’ah.
At the conclusion of the section
dealing with the chatzotzrot,
What does the Torah do?
The Torah resumes the previous theme.
The journeying of the machanes (camps).
And again
tells us in detail the order in which the camps travel.
Judah at the head,
Followed by Yisachar and so forth.
Then, after the Torah describes
the organization of the machanes,
and how they moved from spot to spot
how they traveled,
suddenly we are
we hear the very strange conversation
which actually I mean
prima facie
is puzzling and enigmatic.
a conversation between Moses and his father in law
Moses extending an invitation to his father in law,
but humbly extended.
"And you will serve as eyes for us.
Moreover, if you go with us, whatever good Hashem does for us,
the same we will do for you."
Moshe arguing with his father in law.
He wants his father in law to leave Midyan,
and to join the Bnei Yisrael,
but Yitro is a bit stubborn.
Fine.
Following the conversation,
we suddenly
we suddenly are confronted
with a parsha consisting of two psukim.
Vay’hi bin’soa ha’aron… – Whenever the ark set out,
Moses would say,  [Arise, Hashem, let your enemies be scattered,
and your foes flee before you.”]
"And whenever it came to rest, he would say, [Return, Hashem
of the ten thousand thousands of Israel].”
Two psukim.
At the beginning of the parsha there
there is an inverted noon.
At the end of the parsha there is an inverted noon.
In order to emphasize that this parsha is out of context here.
Indeed, it is out of context.
And the question is obvious.
What is the question? If it's out of context
so why should should the parsha
why did the Torah insert the parsha in the
in the in the place or into a section,
within which the parsha would always stand out
as out of context.
The parsha could have been beautifully inserted.
You know where?
Where could this parsha be inserted?
At the end of Pekudei.
At the end of Exodus.
"For the cloud of Hashem was on the tabernacle by day,
and fire was in the cloud by night,
before the eyes of all the house of Israel at each stage of their journey."
The two psukim
would have been the most appropriate conclusion or sequel to that.
"Whenever the ark set out, Moses would say,
Arise, Hashem, let your enemies be scattered, and your foes flee before you.”
"And whenever it came to rest, he would say,
Return, Hashem of the ten thousand thousands of Israel.”
And finally,
following the parsha of Vay’hi bin’soa ha’aron,
the Torah tells us the tragic story. Very tragic story.
We will analyze this story.
Of the Kivrot haTa’avah.
Of the people who desired. They didn't do anything else.
No crime, no avoda zara, no retsicha.
No giluy arayot.
No gezayla, no genayva.
Nothing.
They hadn't raised their voices.
They just were overcome by a desire.
And they wept.  That's all.
They didn't yell.
They didn't throw stones at Moses.
Like their actions in other situations.
Nothing.  They didn't say anything.
They were not threatening anybody.
Just complaining.
People have a desire.
This tragic story is told
and the name Kivrot haTa’avah
could have been invented today
to characterize, to portray, modern man.
It is the grave of the desire.
The grave which man digs for himself.
Or I would rather say,
the grave which the desire digs for man.
The grave of the voluptuaries.
And finally
the conclusion of the sidra is
the story of Miriam.
We simply are perplexed.
How many stories are in Beha'alotcha?
One story or several stories? Or many stories?
What do you think?
Several? I'm not asking for the number.
It will be wrong
whatever number you mention.
But I'm asking one or many?
If it's one, there must be transition;
If there is no transition,
there is no gradual and systematic development
of a theme, there is no unity.
Whoever writes a composition paper,
in first year of English,
knows there must be unity!
Unity is when a theme is developed.
Prima Facie there is no development of anything, there is no unity.
There's no literary unity.
There are many stories.
But each story per se is half a story, not a complete story.
With you, I mean when I
as a matter of fact whatever I'll tell you tonight
I mean I
occurred to me during kriyat haTorah on Shabbos.
It's completely new.  You wouldn't find it.
No one plagiarized me yet.
I'm just reviewing my thoughts with you tonight for the first time.
I had a feeling when the ba'al koreh
was reading the sidra,
as if we were jumping like a bee
on a clear warm summer morning from flower to flower
accumulating the sweet nectar.
Is it possible let me ask you
is it possible that the principal of achdus
of achdus haTorah, unity of the Torah,
of the scenes which the Torah develops,
was lost in the parsha of Beha'alotcha?
It's an impossibility.
Now let me move forward and see
I mean of course
my job is
to restore the unity of the parsha.
The parsha is one story.
One story, a tragic story.
Tragic story
which has changed Jewish history completely.
From top to bottom. The inverted Nuns
symbolize an inverted historical process here.
An inverted Nun is not so bad.
But if history is being inverted,
not realized, or stopped suddenly,
it's very tragic.
Chazal speak about punishment in Beha'alotcha
as the worst distressful event Jewish history.
“In order to separate between one punishment and another punishment.”
Let us start with the Exodus.
When the almighty
charged Moshe with the assignment of redeeming
the
the Jews
or liberating them from Egypt
He told them the following words.
He told him many things.
But the Chinuch says,
That the necessary prerequisite of the Exodus is the following sentence:
"And it shall be your sign that it was I who sent you, when you will free the people from Egypt,
you shall worship Gd on this mountain."
"And it shall be your sign that it was I who sent you,
when you will free the people from Egypt,
you shall worship Gd on this mountain."
It's a difficult sentence.  Difficult verse.
In other words,
I'm utilizing, plagiarizing the Ba'al Hachinuch,
In other words, the Almighty told Moses
that the Exodus drama will culminate
in two events:
"You shall worship Gd on this mountain."
How many events does this encompass?
How many events?
It means that the Exodus
will not be consummated
until you worship Gd at this mountain.
What does Gd mean by it?
Worship Gd at this mountain.
What did He mean by it?
What did Moshe understand by these words?
"Worship Gd at this mountain."
Very simply, what does it mean?
So the Chinuch says,
he meant two things.
First of all Matan Torah,
the giving of the law.
The Torah teaches man how to worship Gd.
The continuous worship of Gd.
The Man who lives according to the principles and rules of the Torah
is a steady worshipper of Gd.
There is no neutral moment;
worship is a continuous process.
However, he meant something else,
Namely what?
The construction of the Mishkan.
Certainly within the purpose of the Mishkan,
Is what?  Is the worship
as a matter of fact the Torah was given at
at the Mount Sinai
and the Mishkan was constructed when?
immediately after Moses came down from the
from the mountain
and immediately Betzalel started
the work of constructing the Mishkan
on the day or the following day after Moses
I mean came down from the mountain
assembled the people
and told them that the Mishkan should be constructed.
It's no wonder that
following the 10 Commandments,
following in Parshas Yisro
Gd mentioned
to Moses what? The construction of a mizbeach.
If the Jews hadn't succumbed to the hysteria of the Erev Rav.
Had they rejected the Egel,
the two objectives would have been realized much sooner.
Because of the Egel,
the time schedule was changed and the consummation of the
of "You shall worship Gd on this mountain",
was delayed for how many days?
For how many days?
80 days correct.
if the Egel had not been made and
and the whole tragedy of the Egel could have been avoided,
so Moshe would have come down on the 17th of Tamuz,
and immediately
they would have started to construct the Mishkan.
Because of the Egel
Moshe had to spend on Mount Sinai, in prayer,
80 more days.
So Moshe came back from Mount Sinai,
The day following Yom Kippur.
And so the construction of the Mishkan was delayed for 80 days.
However,
on the day after Yom Kippur
after Moses came down with the second luchos,
and with the message of forgiveness,
he quickly assemble the congregation
and told them about the immediate task to be discharged
namely the binyan Beis Hamikdash.
The work of construction commenced immediately.
How long did it take them
to construct the Mishkan? To complete the work?
How long? The Mishkan was completed and put together
on the 1st of Nissan.
According to Chazal
it was the Shemini laMiluim (8th day of the Miluim handing over the priesthood to Aharon)
The day on which the Nesiim began to offer
their gifts to the
to the Beis Hamikdash.
When
When those two objectives.
Matan Torah,
and binyan Beis Hamikdash, were achieved
so the Geula found its realization.
"You shall worship Gd on this mountain" was translated into reality.
The people therefore had no business of prolonging
their stay in Midbar Sinai.
They stayed in Midbar Sinai as long as they wanted.
As long as it was necessary to receive the Torah.
The Torah had to be received twice
due to the Egel.
and as long as it was necessary to construct
as long as it was necessary in order to complete the work on the Beis Hamikdash.
Because both come under the
are encompassed by the
by the commandment: "Worship Gd on this mountain".
But the very moment
the second Luchos were delivered to Yisrael,
The Beis Hamikdash was constructed.
The work completed.
Zekenim elected,
and the korbanos offered,
so then the task of Yisrael
in Midbar Sinai was discharged and fulfilled.
There was no purpose in
in extending the sojourn any longer.
Now let us see.
The Torah in Naso tells us about the final act of the
of the dedication of the Mishkan.
Namely, the sacrifices by the Nesiim.
The Torah did not forget to mention
a secondary
matter like the Kiddush Haleviim.
The Torah
apprises us in Tzav about Kiddush Kohanim.
Which was a primary significance.
In a word, with the dedication of the Mishkan
by the Nesiim,
and the election of the Leviim,
everything which was necessary in order to have
the Mishkan serve the great purpose of Avoda,
was prepared and ready.
The work was completed.
As a matter of fact,
when could the Bnei Yisrael
simply get up and leave
and leave Midbar Sinai?
The Mishkan was completed on the 1st of Nissan.
12 Nesiim offered their gifts.
The Almighty said:
"They shall present their offerings, one leader each day, for the dedication of the altar…"
meaning Rosh Chodesh Nissan plus 12 days.
It means they were ready on the 13th of Nissan to march.
However the Anan (cloud) did not move, did not rise.
Because the next day was Erev Pesach.
To march Erev Pesach, tomorrow is the korban Pesach.
So the march was postponed until after Pesach.
But everybody knew
that the stay of the Jews in Midbar Sinai
in the Sinai wilderness came to a close.
The job was done, the task discharged,
the Beis Hamikdash built, the Torah was given,
now we have to resume our march.
However, the march was, as I said, delayed.
Until after the Jews offered the Korban Pesach.
The second Pesach
they celebrated in Midbar Sinai,
"Hashem spoke to Moses in the wilderness of Sinai, in the first month of the second year
after they had come out of the land of Egypt, saying:
Let the Israelites keep the passover at its appointed time."
I postponed the journey,
Until after the Korban Pesach will be offered.
So why did the Torah tell us
In Beha'alotcha about the Korban Pesach
the second year?
Because the Korban Pesach was the only handicap
the only obstacle as far as what?
As the resumption of the march is concerned.
And during the Hakravas HaPesach
impure people inquired about their status,
Moshe Rabenu asked the Almighty,
and the institution of Pesach Sheni was introduced.
For those who were unable to offer the Pesach
on the 1st of Nissan.
There is topic continuity.
The kiddush Haleviim is the last act
of "You shall worship Gd on this mountain".
It was not as important as the kiddush HaKohanim.
That's why the Torah tells us about the sanctification of the Kohanim
in Tzav and Tetzaveh.
The sanctification of the Leviim is not as important;
you could operate the Beis HaMikdash without the Leviim.
Shira (the main function of the Leviim) is not indispensable;
the Leviim are more or less a luxury.
The Torah tells us that every detail was completed,
we were ready to march,
the Almighty told Moshe to offer the Pesach first in Midbar Sinai,
and after the Pesach was offered,
the B’nei Yisrael were supposed to resume their march.
I repeat
the two prerequisites for moving on were met.
The Torah given and accepted,
the Mishkan ready for worship.
The great march was supposed to start.
The march where?
There was one place they had to march.
Not back to Egypt.
The march to Eretz Yisrael.
All four freedoms
all four freedoms were attained.
“I will take out…
I will save…
I will redeem…”,
and with Matan Torah and the construction of the Mikdash,
the “I will take…” was realized as well.
The hour was struck for the fifth freedom
for the fifth freedom
to be realized and translated into a reality.
namely “I will bring (you into the land…)”.
Now,
how long was the march supposed to last?
What did you say?
A year?
Two years?
No.
A short time anyway, several days
We'll see how many days Chazal end up with.
Several days.
That's why the Torah reveals to us
the details of the march.
First, who was the guide,
who was the leader?
if you march toward a certain destination
particularly in the desert, you need a leader.
So the answer is, the Torah gives an answer.
who was the leader of that march?
Who was the guide?
The Amud Ha'Anan (the pillar of cloud)
Amud Ha'Anan was an instrument in the hands of the Almighty.
The guide was the Almighty.
the Torah told us in B’shallach:
"Hashem went in front of them in a pillar of cloud by day,
to lead them along the way, and in a pillar of fire by night, to give them light,
so that they might travel by day and by night.
Now the Torah tells us how the camps were arranged marching.
Which tribes formed the avant garde and which tribes formed the rear guard:
M’asef lekhol haMachanot.
The Torah speaks of Tziv’otam (hosts) of warriors:
Kol Yotz’ei Tzava.
The Torah also relates to us
the story of the two Hatzotzrot in this context
because it’s very important.
The story of the signal system.
Moshe was the commander
he directed and instructed the
various camps, on the march
to the Promised Land. There was need for communication.
And the means of communication were the two silver trumpets, the Hatzotzrot of silver.
And if you read carefully Beha'alotcha,
Beha'alotcha is a long sidra,
the baal korehs rush through the sidra.
So you feel the feeling of the psukim,
"And they marched from the mountain of Gd a distance of 3 days.
And the Ark of the Covenant traveled in front of them on that three days’ journey
to seek out a resting place for them."
And "when both are blown..." "if only one is blown..."
"when you blow a T’ruah, the camps on the east side shall set out;
when you blow a second T’ruah, the camps on the south side shall set out.
A T’ruah is to be blown whenever they are to set out."
What do you feel in that?
I mean I felt it.
Torah is not only important to explain intellectually in categories,
but also in emotional categories.
You want to understand the beauty
and the greatness of the Torah,
the emotional mood which is created by kriyas HaTorah
is perhaps more important than the
than the intellectual gesture.
What do you feel?
I feel a mood of expectancy and tension.
A mood of expectancy permeates the pages of Beha'alotcha.
There is, you feel a mood
there is a mood of mobilization
and rigid order
in the air.
All conditions were met,
the reward is about to be granted,
finally finally the promise to Abraham
is about to be fulfilled.
"I will bring..." will become the 5th freedom.
The people are on their final triumphal march.
Now in this context, I would rather say in this mood,
Moshe was excited.
It was very hard to excite Moshe.
He was expecting great things.
There is tenseness in the air.
And there is determination, boldness to break through if neccesary.
Interesting, is the conversation between Moses
and his father in law.
What does it mean?
What kind of a mood on the part of Moshe
is mirrored, or reflected,
by this conversation.
We get a glimpse into Moses, into his mood.
Those days
after the second Passover,
when the Pesach was offered,
and the people started to march.
"In the second year, in the second month, on the twentieth day of the month,
the cloud lifted from over the tabernacle of the covenant.
Then the Israelites set out by stages…"
It was not one of many journeys...
It was THE journey! The final journey!
After that journey,
Moshe expected there would be no need to journey anymore, to travel.
What does the conversation
the inner nation the favour of Israel
the favour of whoever the John has the creation nation
“We are setting out for the place of which Hashem said, ‘I will give it to you’;
come with us, and we will treat you well; for Hashem has promised good to Israel.”
What impression do you get?
What is the emotional climate of that?
It is a climate of serenity,
peace of mind
an unqualified assurance.
Moses spoke
of the final journey to the Promised Land.
no waiting anymore.
No Ani Ma’amin – I believe in the coming of Mashiach,
even if he may tarry, I will wait for him…
There would be no need for it anymore.
No delays,
no procrastination,
no if and no when:
Im Shamo’a Tishm’u – If you will listen –
It is now!
It is going to happen now.  Right now!
Not tomorrow.  Right now.
Moses said to Hobab son of Reuel the Midianite, Moses’ father-in-law,
“We are setting out”
It is present tense, not “We will set out”
rather,  “We are setting out”…
for the place of which Hashem said,
‘I will give it to you’; come with us, and we will treat you well;
for Hashem has promised good to Israel.
All the promises will be fulfilled!
I won’t have to ask questions
why have you mistreated this people?
Why did you ever send me? Ever since I came to Pharaoh…
No problems, no questions, no doubts.
Nothing.
It will be very simple.
And I want to let you in on another secret.
It was not an invitation
extended to the father in law.
It's not an invitation
which a son in law extends to his father in law.
It was not an invitation extended by an individual to another human being
to share the good things in life.
It was more than that.
It was an invitation extended to whom?
by Moses, representing Klal Yisrael,
to whom?
To all Gerim.
To all Gerim of all generations.
The Midrash in Kohelet says:
“All of the rivers flow into the sea and the sea is never filled”
these are the Gerim who come to Eretz Yisrael to convert.
It was extended to all Gerim.
to the entire non-Jewish world.
Join us!
To come to join us
in the Promised Land.
Provided, of course, there is one condition.
We have one condition.
According to Halacha.
No ifs and no whens.
To come to join us in the Promised Land,
Provided that the non-Jew is ready to subject himself to the same Divine discipline as we did.
Any human being
was offered the opportunity
to join the march to the Promised Land.
The march to be
to the Messianic era.
If that march had been realized,
the coming of Mashiach would have taken place when?
Then. Moses would have been the Mashiach.
It was quite optional.
The Jews could have reached it.
They lost it.
They lost it,
so Moses is not the Mashiach,
And the distance in time between them is long
and far.
The Torah was given to us.
Certainly.
Eretz Yisrael was granted to us, certainly.
However,
we were told to pass on Gd’s word
to mankind as such.
We all remember the famous verse
in Shofarot of Rosh HaShana:
“All you inhabitants of the world, you who live on the earth,
when a signal is raised on the mountains, look!  When a trumpet is blown, listen!”
We are all invited – all the dwellers on this world.
We are setting out for the place of which Hashem said,
‘I will give it to you’; come with us, and we will treat you well…
What does Moshe think?
That Yitro, the non-Jew, is dependent upon us?
Our Torah is commodious enough
to encompass the entire world.
There is enough chesed, goodness, and happiness in the Torah,
to be transmitted to others
and to be shared by others.
Join our triumphal march, Moshe said to Yitro,
towards our destiny.
It may become your destiny as well.
And when I read this Parsha,
it attracts me.
There is something moving,
touching, in that Parsha.
Sometimes I want to cry
when I read this Parsha.
Something moving, something touching.
I want to cry.
I have to control my tears.
what is moving here, is the simplicity,
the way in which the great Moshe
the master of all wise men,
and the father of all prophets, speaks.
What do I mean?
He uses the grammatical first person:
We are setting out…
come with us, and we will treat you well…
whatever good Hashem does for us…
What does it mean?
Moshe was certain –
there was not even a shadow of doubt in his mind –
that he is going to enter the Promised Land.
He and the entire congregation
will be classified as both
Yotz’ei Mitzrayim (departers from Egypt) and Ba’ei ha’Aretz (those who come into the Land).
He was sure.
He was convinved.
That he would see the beautiful land,
the hills of Judea,
and the prairie land of the Sharon Valley,
he was certain
that we will climb the mount of Levanon.
Later he prayed, but his prayer did not come true:
“…Let me cross over to see the good land
beyond the Jordan, that good hill country and the Lebanon.”
But that time he felt no need for prayer:
We are setting out…
come with us, and we will treat you well…
whatever good Hashem does for us…
There was no doubt about his destiny.
The whole operation, if successfully brought to a close
would have lasted several days.
And at that time there was no need for Meraglim, for scouts to explore the land,
to see whether the land is good or bad,
or to see whether the cities are surrounded by walls or they are open cities,
what kind of population is there –
strong, weak, a sickly population or a healthy population.
There was no need for it.
all those scouts and all the exploration and intelligence work
is only necessary if a man has doubts.
This was the pre-doubt period in Jewish history.
We are setting out for the place of which Hashem said,
‘I will give it to you’; come with us, and we will treat you well…
Share with us! An open invitation to everybody.
Yitro or no Yitro, father-in-law of Moshe or the stranger.
The Torah tells us indeed,
And they journeyed from the mount of the Eternal three days journey,
and the Ark of the Covenant went before them in the three days journey
to seek out a Menucha (resting place) for them,
And they journeyed from the mount of the Eternal three days journey,
and the Ark of the Covenant went before them in the three days journey
Where did it go?
Where is Menucha for the Jews?
What was the destination?
Rashi, quoting Sifri, says:
A distance of three days journey
they miraculously traveled in one day,
because the Almighty wanted to bring them into Eretz Yisrael right away.
A distance of three days journey,
they miraculously traveled in one day,
because the Almighty
wanted to bring them into Eretz Yisrael.
Into the land.
So my dear friends, tell me
at that time
before the great reversal took place,
was the Parsha of Vay’hi bin’soa’ ha’aron in its proper place or out of context?
Before the Jews alienated God,
before they fell from Him.
and they needed Meraglim as scouts and they had doubts.
Before, every Jew was convinced:
This is the final consummation of all hope.
It was beautiful, the Torah tells us:
And they journeyed from the mount of the Eternal three days journey,
and the Ark of the Covenant went before them in the three days journey
to seek out a Menucha
the cloud of Hashem being over them by day when they set out from the camp.
(meaning security on all sides)
Vay’hi Binsoa’ ha’aron – Whenever the ark set out (leading them right into Eretz Yisrael)
Moses would say,
“Arise, Hashem, let your enemies be scattered, and your foes flee before you.”
Who were the enemies?
As a matter of fact,
The last war they fought was the war against Amalek.
The next war was against Sichon and Og,
40 years later.
Why was Moshe speaking about enemies and fiends and people who threatened them?
Who did Moshe have in mind?
We are traveling fast to Eretz Yisrael –
there we will be confronted by somebody.
If the great hope had been realized,
there would have been no need to engage in battle for seven years.
Whenever the ark set out, Moses would say,
Arise, Hashem, let your enemies be scattered, and your foes flee before you.”
And whenever it came to rest, he would say,
Return, Hashem of the ten thousand thousands of Israel.”
It was not misplaced.
It was right.
It was the continuation of the great story of the final,
triumphal Messianic march into Eretz Yisrael,
which was supposed to take place approximately 3500 years ago.
It was certainly in its place
and there was no need for an inverted Nun
at the beginning and for an inverted Nun at the end.
It was actually
it would have been the climax, or the appex of the whole story.
Had this come true,
nothing had happened,
The whole Jewish history
would have taken a different turn.
According to our tradition,
(Chazal said it many times)
had Moshe entered Eretz Yisrael,
the latter never would have been taken from us –
Why?
Because Moses would have been crowned as the Melekh haMashiach.
The Messianic era would have commenced
with the conquest of the land by Moses.
Moshe believed
with a great passion
and love
that the final march of redemption had begun –
it was only a question of days.
Suddenly, something happened.
Something happened.
Neither Moshe
nor the Almighty,
nor anybody else,
expected the event to transpire.
I asked you before.  What happened, actually?
By the Egel, you know what happened.
About the Meraglim (spies) we know what happened.
About Pe’or in Midian, 40 years later,
we know what happened.
What happened here?
What happened?
Nothing in particular.
If you want you can dismiss it.
“And the multitude that was among them felt a lust.”
That's all.  They had a desire.
And the children of Israel also wept again, and they said,
who shall give us flesh to eat?
And the Torah tells us,
that this seizure by a desire,
or a lust,
was evil.
It aroused the wrath of the Almighty
and also Moshe resented it.
In Moshe’s eyes it was evil –
Uv’einei Moshe ra
First time in Jewish history.
Moshe was not the defense attorney:
It is evil.
This interrupted the great march.
It has brought the march to an end.
The vision of Mashiach,
of Eretz Yisrael,
of the redemption of Yisrael,
became a distant one,
like a distant star,
on a mysterious horizon.
It twinkled.
But the road suddenly became almost endless.
Why?
Why did Moshe feel discouraged?
Why didn’t he offer
prayers for the people as was his practice in past situations?
What happened?
Because the incident
of Kivrot haTa’avah differed greatly from that of the Egel.
The making of the Egel was the result
of great primitive fright.
The people thought that Moses was dead,
they were afraid of the desert.
They did not know what the future held
in store for them.
They were simply overwhelmed
by a feeling of loneliness and terror.
Consequently, they violated the precept of Avodah Zarah.
There were mitigating circumstances.
They wanted the Golden Calf to substitute for Moses.
as all the Rishonim (medieval commentators) say.
However, when you speak about Avodah Zarah,
you have to distinguish between two things.
Between Avodah Zarah, idolatry,
simply as a ritual, as a worship,
and between a pagan way of life.
As a matter of fact,
in Chazal’s opinion,
an Avodah Zarah worshipper will also adopt the pagan way of life.
But, we know,
in this day and age,
we know that it's possible
for people to live like pagans,
even though no idolatry is involved.
Paganism is not the worship of an idol.
It encompasses more than the worship
of an idol.
A certain style of life.
A way of life.
What is the pagan way of life
in contradistinction to the Torah way of life?
The pagan cries for variety.
For boundlessness.
For unlimited lust.
And insatiable desire.
The demonic dream of total conquest.
Of drinking the cup of pleasure to its dregs.
The pagan way of life is the very antithesis of Yahadus.
The latter demands limitedness
of enjoyment and the ability to step backwards if necessary,
the ability to withdraw – to retreat.
The unlimited desire, which the Greeks call hedone,
is the worst form
is actually the worst desire
in Man.
When Man reaches out for the unreachable,
When Man reaches out for the orgiastic and hypnotic,
then they don’t violate the prohibition of Avodah Zarah,
but they adopt the pagan a way of life.
And the Torah hated the pagan way of life more than it hated the idol.
Because an idol cannot exist
for a long time.
It cannot last.
Finally, an intelligent person realizes that it is just wood and metal;
It has no life.
Avodah Zarah per se is short-lived.
However, a pagan way of life,
has a tremendous attraction for people.
The Torah
describes so beautifully the way
in which the pagan gathers,
accumulates property –
gathers the Slav, the quail.
How he gathers property,
means of gratification
of his hungry senses.
“So the people worked all that day and night”
That’s how the Torah describes it.
“And all the next day, gathering the quails;
The least anyone gathered was ten homers;
And they spread them out for themselves all around the camp.”
They were mad with desire,
There was no controlling, limiting element in their desire for vastness.
The imagination actually excited them.
And their good sense was surrounded with a nimbus which was irresistible.
The more, the better.
And you start gathering new goods even before
you have completed gathering the other goods.
The pagan is impatient and insatiable.
That ‘s what the Torah describes in Kivrot haTa’avah.
There’s another story in the Torah which,
in contradistinction to the unlimited desire of the pagan,
the Torah describes the Jewish way of life.
It's interesting,
it's the Manna.
And Moses said to them:
This is the bread which the Lord has given you to eat,
gather as much of it as each of you
is required to eat.
An omer to a person, for as many of you as there are.
But when they measured it,
by the omer,
he who gathered much had no excess,
and he who gathered little had no deficiency.
This is the approach of Yahadus.
The great tragedy happened,
the triumphal final march suddenly came to a stop.
A people who rejected the basic principle
of economic
limitedness and aesthetic enjoyment,
these people were not worthy to enter the Land.
Suddenly., what happened?
The Parsha of Vay’hi binsoa’ ha’aron
found itself displaced, dislocated.
The march
to that land,
I mean, the distance to that land,
suddenly became very long.
Of course, there was no edict yet concerning the 40 years.
The time the people would have to spend in the desert.
But Moses felt intuitively
that the great march had come to an end.
Hopes he had will be unfulfilled.
And visions he had will not be realized.
And his prayers will be rejected.
He knew that.
I tell you frankly, I don’t have to say
Moses was the master of the prophets,
he knew Gd didn’t reveal it to him.
I remember from my own experience,
during the illness of my wife.
She was sick for four years.
And of course,
I am a realist.
And it is very hard to fool me.
Not even doctors can fool me.
But, somehow I was convinced
that somehow she would manage to get out of it.
And I lived with hope
and tremendous unlimited faith.
I remember, it was the last Yom Kippur before she died.
And it was Kol Nidrei
and I was holding a Sefer Torah for Kol Nidrei
and when the Chazan finished Kol Nidrei and said
Shehech’yanu veqiy’manu vehigi’anu laz’man hazeh
I turned over the Sefer Torah to a Talmid of mine.
And I told him to put it in the Aron Kodesh.
He put it in the Aron Kodesh,
apparently he didn’t place it well, I don’t know what,
but the Sefer Torah slipped
and fell.
Not on the floor, but in the Aron Kodesh.
At that time I was filled –
don’t ask me how or why –
I felt a gefil –
Nothing will help.
And indeed it was.
When the Am haMit’avim (the people who had the craving)
began to complain and to weep,
Moses knew, this is the end.
He’ll never see Eretz Yisrael.
Never.
That’s why he said:
If this is the way you are going to treat me,
put me to death at once…
and do not let me see my misery.
And how beautifully the Chazal said:
“Eldad and Meidad were having prophecy in the camp”
What did they say?
What was the excitement about?
They said just one short sentence:
Moshe‘s hopes,
“We are setting out…
come with us, and we will treat you well…”
Will never come true.
Moshe will die.
He’ll be buried in the sand dunes in the desert –
he’ll never see the beautiful land and the Levanon –
Moshe meit viY’hoshua makhnis.
Moshe will die and Yehoshua will lead [the people] in to the Land.
And then the parashas Vay’hi binsoa’ ha’aron
Suddenly lost its place.
It was dislocated and displaced.
Do you know why it was dislocated and displaced?
Because two little Nuns were inverted –
The march was inverted.
Instead of the march bringing them closer to Eretz Yisrael,
the march took them away from Eretz Yisrael.
Binsoa’ ha’aron
the Nun was inverted.
and with the inversion of the Nun,
Jewish history became inverted.
and it is still inverted.
The Parsha is still “dislocated”.
We cannot say “we are setting forth”
with the assurance and certitude
with which Moshe said it to Yitro his father-in-law
just 24 hours before the Mit’avim
inverted the Jewish process of redemption.
Finally, is now the continuation of the Parsha –
I didn’t yet explain the problem of Miriam,
which I will now explain.
The Torah describes the construction of the Mikdash,
the Torah describes the Exodus,
Matan Torah in Parashat Yitro,
the construction of the Mikdash in Parashat Teruma.
Suddenly, something happened which interrupted the continuity –
the Egel.
The construction was delayed for a certain number of days.
Finally the Beis Hamikdash was ready.
Sefer Vayyikra (Leviticus) is devoted completely
to the worship, to “you shall worship God on this mountain.”
Then in Bamidbar (Numbers) the Torah still tells us
about the last act of dedication by the Nesi’im (princes).
And the lighting of the candles.
And the sanctification of the Levi’im.
So “you shall worship Gd on this mountain” was attained,
the two objectives were reached,
now the march began.
The Torah tells us how the Jews were marching
on the final triumphal march on the final triumphal journey to Eretz Yisrael.
The pillar of cloud covered them,
protected them, shielded them.
It was in front and was also the rear guard protecting them in back.
And then how Moshe communicated with the camps,
the Chatzotzrot of silver,
and Moshe’s conversation with Yitro.
He already had Eretz Yisrael within his reach,
he extended the generous invitation to mankind,
to share in our Ge’ulah – our redemption,
and everything was ready.
Vay’hi Bin’soa’ ha’aron –
They had to take just a few more days.
During the last few days, something happened –
disaster struck.
And that disaster has inverted Jewish History,
and that disaster dislocated the Parshat Vay’hi Bin’soa’ ha’aron.
And that disaster inverted the march –
instead of marching to Eretz Yisrael,
we began to march away from Eretz Yisrael.
Moshe discovered something else –
Moses realized something else.
He knew pretty well
that he was chosen as the teacher of Klal Yisrael.
Gd did not elect him as a diplomat,
as a negotiator,
but as the teacher, or the rebbe of the people.
As their spiritual and moral leader.
Gd Himself told him, when Moshe asked:
“Who am I, that I should go to Phar’aoh?”
He said: “you shall worship God on this mountain”.
Basically, Moshe, had I been looking for a negotiator,
I wouldn’t have selected you.
But I'm not looking for a negotiator.
I can do the work of negotiating by myself.
I need a teacher for my people.
As a teacher, you yourself will agree
that you are the best one.
You are a teacher par excellence.
And that’s why I selected you:
‘And it shall be your sign’ –
and that is the reason (the Chinuch writes that).
That I selected you and not somebody else.
There were many people in Egypt who were qualified to be negotiators;
because the purpose of the Exodus is not political freedom,
but the conversion of a slave society into a Kingdom of Kohanim and a holy nation.
And for that you are wonderful.
Moshe knew this.
However,
he did not expect, until the Mit’avim,
that he would assume the role not only of a teacher,
that he was ready to do since the Exodus.
But of whom?
Of a nursing mother or father – an Omein.
What is an Omein?
Omein is not a Rav.
Omein is a nursing father or mother.
Of course, a nursing mother teaches the baby.
Perhaps the mother is the best and most important teacher
in the life of a baby.
But she does something else –
namely,
the rebbe teaches the talmidim.
The Omein, the nursing mother,
in addition to teaching,
does something else.
She carries the baby in her bosom or in her arms.
“…as a nurse carries a sucking child.”
What does it mean that he carries the baby
in his bosom and in his arms,
or in her bosom and in her arms.
Usually the father doesn’t do it, the mother does it.
The father has no patience for that.
The mother does it.
What does it mean she carries it?
Actually it is true literally.
But it has more meaning
than the word literally contains.
What does it mean?
The teacher does teach his disciple,
but the disciple does not become a part of him.
Very seldom.
When the mother teaches the baby,
the baby becomes a part of her.
The mother, when she rears the baby,
or when she nurses the baby,
has one calling,
one purpose.
To protect the baby.
The Omein or the mother
basically do not belong to themselves.
Many may be very critical of my statement
but this is true according to Yahadus.
The mother has no life of her own.
She belongs to the infant.
At least as long as the infant is small, helpless
and exposed to danger, to the environment.
To a hostile environment.
She belongs to the infant.
Moshe discovered now
that teaching is not enough for a leader of Yisrael.
It's not enough.
The teacher, no matter how devoted,
has a life of his own
That his job is nursing,
carrying the baby in his arms,
watching every step
guessing the baby’s needs.
A baby cannot say what she wants, you have to guess.
Feeling
Feeling pain
when the baby cries.
And being happy when the baby is cheerful.
Teaching or instructing her good performances,
but that is not everything.
Moses, who reconciled with his role as a teacher and leader of adults,
began to doubt his ability
to play the role of an Omen or mother nurse.
Listen to his words:
Did I conceive all these people,
did I bear them, that you say to me: Carry them in your bosom
as a nurse carries an infant?
Moses knew,
he discovered,
something very tragic in a mother’s life.
What did he discover?
He knew that from now on
he is an individual
he has no rights at all.
He as an individual, has no rights at all.
He has no rights.
He has no right to rejoice,
whenever Gd will be good to him.
As a private person,
he is not entitled to enjoy life as an individual,
to be happy in an ordinary way
like any other human being.
Because his children
will never belong to Moshe.
He lost his family.
He became the mother
or the nurse of the Klal Yisrael.
No family of his own.
And that's what Chazal say.
He separated himself from his wife.
It isn’t just his wife from whom he separated.
It’s the wife and children (two lovely boys).
He had a sister,
he had a brother.
He knew he could not share his joy with them.
They cannot share their joy with him.
He is the father of Klal Yisrael.
And that is what he says.
The role of “as a nurse carries a sucking child”
was imposed upon him during the rebellion of the Mit’onenim.
He separated himself,
he withdrew not only from his mate, Tzipora,
but also from his children.
Tell me, where are Moshe’s children?
Did you ever come across Moshe’s children?
Ever?
There was a census taken in the Midbar,
at the beginning of the 40 years
and at the end of the 40 years.
Are Moshe’s children mentioned?
Not once.
This is the lineage of Moses and Aaron...
These are the names of the sons of Aaron:
Nadab, and Abihu, Eleazar, and Ithamar;
Where are Moshe’s children?
Moshe did not have children.
And it is later, in Tanach,
The Bible,
the name of Moses’ child
was mentioned,
not as the son of Moshe, but the son of “Menasheh”.
A little Nun was added to the word.  Why?
Not only in order to reflect unfavorably upon Moshe
this is ridiculous.
Moses was not responsible for what happened
because Moshe did not have children.
I always say
if Moses had a child,
then according to the law he would have been in a most awful dilemma.
According to the law, it would have been required of him
to give preference to his child,
as far as the study of Torah is concerned,
over the child of his next-door neighbor.
This is a law which Moshe Rabbenu taught us:
Your own son takes precedence (in teaching Torah) over the son of your fellow.
On the other hand,
Moshe had no right to give any preference,
or to give an additional second to his son,
because he was the father of every child within the Jewish community.
So Moshe lost his children.
He became the Omein, the nursing mother,
of K’lal Yisrael.
And that is exactly what Gd told him
at the time of Matan Torah:
You say to them,
return to your tents, to your private lives,
but you, stay here.
You say to them, return to your tents,
to your private lives,
but you, stay here.
Moshe realized it
during the incident of the Mit’onenim.
And that is what Miriam,
the true, loyal sister, resented.
Does prophecy require of Man
alienation of his family?
Does Gd require of the prophet
that he should forget his sister and brother,
his children and wife,
and dedicate himself only to the people?
…Has He not spoken through us also?
And we live a beautiful life
with our husbands and children and relatives.
And it doesn’t interfere with our devotion to the people.
That’s exactly what Gd resented and told her:
There is a difference between you and Moses.
Yes,
An ordinary prophet does not have to sacrifice his private interest,
his selfish concerns,
his family, his father, mother children,
brother, sister;
He can be a prophet
and communicate with Gd,
and at the same time be a devoted father,
a loving brother,
and a helpful head of the family.
“Not so my servant Moshe.”
He’s consecrated fully and wholly to me.
And that's
how the Parsha of B’haalot’kha
concludes its long story –
it’s one story, this story –
of a great march
which could have led us
into the Messianic era.
On that day, God will be one
and His Name one.
But which was interrupted
by some multitude which was permissive,
hedone seekers.